warning the following episode features
stuns and recipes performed by a
professional chef and they cook and
under the supervision of medical help
accordingly Gordon Ramsay and the
producers insist that no one attempts to
recreate any stunts on this episode of
scrambled but you can try to make the
recipe at your own risk
good keen luck if you turn now omelet
out I will staple my ass together in a
heartbeat I swear to go getting out of
the [ __ ] pan
welcome to scramble where I'm inviting
new friends into my kitchen to make eggs
so today
trust me I'm happy as a pig in [ __ ]
because I have a prankster trickster and
one of the craziest guys I know welcome
bud good to see you and your gifts I did
I have my own brand of hot sauce it's
called steve-o's hot sauce for your foot
right there anyway alright did you know
the tissues on your butthole the same
tissues around your mouth I did not know
that good already yeah but my butthole
has great taste quick question yes the
most famous chef on the planet and I've
got a guess that means that your knives
are sharp razor razor I swear to god I
can't I could lift your king genes up
now and shave your calf it's quite heavy
- where's all the handle because if you
come from with a handle the blade takes
care of itself nothing work for the
knife with a flimsy handle so you need
to find hold that handle firm you come
from with that wait out here are you
comfortable with this you said those
days are gone no no no seriously dumber
than average who come up with the crazy
ideas largely I
with my own ideas and the concept in
general it was born of the skateboarding
industry what this was this kind of an
attitude and and and crazy sort of idiot
stunts was a part of skateboard videos
for many years before so yeah and did
you go at it a hundred mile an hour
thinking [ __ ] I've got this or did you
think get balls to the wall I'm gonna I
thought I was going 100 miles an hour to
my grave I never thought I was gonna
make it to see 30 years old that's why I
didn't care what they paid me because I
wasn't saving for anything breakfast
you've done healthy because you are yeah
I do
right southern style southwestern open
it okay I get around a breakfast yes
after I meditate after coffee
well I meditate well first I'd take care
of our goats and our dogs and cats well
we have ten animals at the house and I
haven't announced them to the world yet
that might be like them
I got goats right and then no fish no
meat I have fish so you're feeling a
little better
should my damn forties for it's awful
but I'm steve-o in my for it's [ __ ]
powerful it's a jam in a jam right you
ready
that depends on okay Nikon let's start
chopping the peppers face okay we're
doing it together
sure Jesus Christ it's just ice it slice
it huh
I'm down right away yeah seeds in right
okay we didn't think you're just come
and watch me did you Jesus Christ it's
kind of weird not for you sit down [ __ ]
I said I'm in together
Jesus Christ craziest stunt you ever did
and you sort of Jesus so peppers time
starts like right now you know I have
something common because you're actually
born in Wimbledon yeah let me be back
since Nazis will keep in there because
the eggs are to make it a lot more
Marvel as well yes exactly that once you
got that in there take the scallions and
slice your scallions up the refried
beans the beans in there amigo
now cool it down with the two moms in
there at the end as well fresh cilantro
bunch it up and just slice it once in
terms of going through don't over hash
it towards the fine because it's young
cilantro
what were you guys man Jesus Christ wait
take this insole come on now that's the
base so that base can sit in the fridge
for up to three or four days and easily
we just take out a spoon at a time but
the most important thing it sort of just
comes together as it sits in the fridge
it gets stronger and stronger and
stronger as the days go on that's right
take that out and set that on a plate
eggs always crack on a flat surface
super important because everyone else
goes on the side right does it send
shell in into the egg the ball first
okay into the ball first okay
don't seize them yet give a little mix
okay just a touch so get your how did
you know you've blended that hot sauce
perfectly my one and heart I wanted
tasty yep and I just combined those
elements I can't wait for you to try I
can't wait I'm gonna cook this southern
style on it first right I'm gonna put
chicken in mine will shred mine work
those seasoned those eggs we season
they'll go great
also it turns them watery I've seen them
too at least halfway through okay here
we go
and in boom once you've got that mixed
up nicely is evenly distribute across
the pan flatten that out okay so I'm
putting a little bits of chicken in Oh
it's okay yeah nobody just turn the only
Turkish crambles I know it's called
scramble but we're making omelet oh [ __ ]
maybe maybe we can continue this and
sort of make yes okay I'll put that back
on the stove up there right it'll touch
a creme fraiche on there and just spread
that over there that's gonna give a
little bit of sort of tartness to the
omelette and then I'm gonna start
building building out my omelette look
look at that and then generous of this
filling okay and as the color goes on
get my spoon okay yeah it looks like
those goats have shattered your pan now
I'm getting a bit of colour on there and
before the fold
Stevo I'm gonna lightly okay lightly put
that then from there now this is where
the magic comes in no I'm gonna wait to
the end I'm gonna put touch the sauce in
the middle hold that up there I'm gonna
fold fold fold fold and fold and then
from there I come on literally Bend that
over garnish in plate on top fold that
in okay and then look makes this here
and there we are all right
I kind of killed it but we suddenly
can't tell sad anymore because that's
[ __ ] tough man you gotta go for more
and then we have the most amazing
southwestern style omelets
next-of-kin mess I did it's gonna be
delicious
are you telling me asking me well you
know I don't know English but I do know
that my hot sauce is delicious
however my eyeballs have not yet tasted
it so yeah I'm gonna give a little bit
of a of an eye drop here just to get our
meal started properly the temperature of
the sauce is it's plenty hot yeah you
weren't gitmo dad what was your
impression
but is it tasty good
okay thank you I mean ya know you get
that start at Stevo calm it's also
available oh wow
[ __ ] medic [ __ ] stroke you okay man
yeah yeah a cold towel okay yeah cool
Johnson's gonna watch the my teams I
wouldn't even mind a flush oh yeah
thanks bro I thought you joke use the
whole bottle go in your idea okay let's
eat yeah regular all right I'm ready
yeah I'm good
thank you I invited you around to have a
cook-off together to get healthy and you
can stick a [ __ ] so now what's the
feedback noise oh it's starting to swell
[Laughter]
but I can see I can see the sauce tastes
delicious thank you gonna keep going
right but before I do if you're not
already subscribed to Gordon's channel
which I'm sure you are
then damn well subscribe and subscribe
to my channel too oh boy right leave a
comment below and tell us how you think
Steve did not only cooking but with that
sort of I laser surgery with his own hot
sauce god bless